about a facial fear and step
aggressively towards your fear and let a
little fear come in and drive you and
motivate you
what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the one rule
series because I do a lot of top tens
and I look at a ton of content by
successful entrepreneurs and sometimes
the rules they tend to repeat they come
up consistently over and over and over
again so that's the aim with this series
to smush together the most common and
popular rules into one video so today
we're gonna learn how to not let your
fears hold you back also if you want to
know what Mel Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Lisa Nichols and other entrepreneurs
have to say about building confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a 30 second to five minute
video for free every single morning to
help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in description below on a
bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you what it
does is it opens up a checklist and then
your brain goes to work trying to remind
you yeah of that intention that you said
so many times we we we validate who we
are by what we're doing for other people
you know we who we are is what we do
what we give how we love and what I'm
very clear on is that you are giving the
world an example of how they get to love
you and treat you based on the way you
love and treat yourself
[Music]
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change that's not
supposed to be an easy question I think
it's it's this well like I said I think
if you if you study engineering and you
figure out how to design new things then
it's relatively easy to start a company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype the compelling
prototype as soon as possible and then
the you know there's there's a strong
venture capital industry in this country
that will give you funding to take
things to the next level and that that's
all there's to it and you might if you
know tried a few times might may or may
not succeed but I think sometimes people
fear fear starting a company too much
you know to say really what's the worst
that could go wrong you're not gonna
starve to death you know you're not
gonna die of exposure
what's worse things go wrong where every
milestone while you might be excited
about the milestone there's a part of
the milestone that you don't want to
face are you hearing me and listen to me
I knocked out the courseware boom got it
done in order ET why did it take you two
years ET after you finish your
coursework why did it take you two years
to get started with the dissertation I'm
gonna be 100 with you there one look
knocked all the course work out but when
I finally got to the dissertation I had
to get to that demon I had to deal with
it I had to face it face what we're not
talking about elementary school middle
school high school I've had a professor
or two tell me in college that you will
never get your dissertation that that
that while your writing has improved but
in terms of your analysis like you are
not critical enough to do a dissertation
or are you hear what I'm telling you
we're talking about look math I love
math coming up why it is what it is so
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally like it
is what it is right it's not subjective
writing is subjective I've had teachers
to look at my work and
and shipping in the park and the fear to
fear what the fear of rejection
rightness is if my teachers were so
subjective I put my whole heart into it
I put everything I can put and they tell
me edit it again a revision after
revision and it after are you hear what
I'm telling you I had to deal with the
fact that writing has never really been
my strong suit and even though I've
worked hard and I put in hours and hours
in the back of my mind I in the back of
my mind I could hear the teachers say
Ichi you don't have what it takes to get
a dissertation I'm a grown man dealing
with that fear I'm a grown man and
illing with the rejection of getting all
that read all that read on my paper I'm
having to do it over and over and over
and over and come on come on somebody
fills me you feel like you'll do a
hundred and twenty percent you'll give
everything you have and it still won't
be enough I feel you I was there a part
of the milestone is what does I give
everything and it ain't enough
what if I put my whole heart my whole
mind my whole soul into it
eat eat and it's not enough what if I do
it and I fail and so I feel you so
you're just like you're not gonna do it
all because you rather not do it and
find out the truth and I'm telling you
you got to do me a favor we gotta face
your fear and you guys do it anyway your
sweetie had to face his fear that's
right yup I know you see Ichi be slow
and you right I am be smoked but it
don't mean be smart without fear and
don't mean be smart without lure anxiety
it don't mean be smoke and I'm just 120
percent sure no I have to live by faith
- and I made up in my mind ET you gotta
go after eat look I finished my course
work it took me two years why cuz it
took me two years to get over the fear
it took me two years to get over the
anxiety it took me two years to finally
say good I am here I come Goliath you
might be taller than me you might be
bigger than me you might be stronger
than me but I'm coming and I'd rather
die trying
I'd rather die going after this
dissertation I'd rather give everything
I got I really give a year I'd rather
put in work and fail you can not try it
off and I think everybody has fear all
wrong people have so many see
about fear they talk about while I'm
afraid of success no I'm afraid of
failure I'm afraid of intimacy I'm
afraid of heights I'm afraid of this I'm
afraid of that I'm afraid of the other
thing there's actually only two fears
only two and if you're in sales which
you are or even if you're not
life is about persuading people life is
about influencing people and fear is the
invisible force that will make you
ineffective at that it will stop you now
I love JK Rollins as an example I mean
we all know the Harry Potter series but
what a lot of people don't know about
her she talks a lot about fear she
struggled with major depression do you
know she was unemployed and she wrote
the original idea for Harry Potter on a
napkin while she was on state benefits
she was then rejected by 12 publishing
houses and this by the way was after she
was divorced bankrupt and a single mom
of a kid pushed herself pushed herself
pushed herself she talks a lot about
fear and about failure well you know we
know the moral of the story she just
kept going of course she was afraid but
she had the good kind of fear not the
bad kind of fear was there ever a time
in your life where you lost belief in
yourself whoa that many times I've
encountered almost you know death and
then I'm losing it how do you come back
from that experience yes yes how do you
retrain your your body in your mind is
believe in the next record the next
adventure yeah actually very quick an
example for example is the first time I
had to do a record with the Guinness
world record swimming under the ice
say 50 meters one hole here one hole
there one meter of ice and then
breath-hold freezing waters beyond the
Polar Circle situation and then the day
before I had to do the actual record and
went in I had no goggles on I lost a way
because I lost a sight it got frozen the
cornea
the retina and I lost it I did 113
meters she couldn't find the hole and I
couldn't find it all my gosh I almost no
I in the end I fainted it but I did not
feel any agony and I felt actually quite
peaceful after minutes a minute under
the I swimming you exhaust your body and
I got is this narrowed vision boom just
seeing that that's physiological Wow and
then I went down swimming it was all
okay was like I was swimming into the
death unconsciousness and that somebody
grabbed me a diver and he brought me
back to the 50-meter Oh which are you
kept going past the hole yeah yeah yeah
completely off yeah and then it was the
rehearsal so the diver was are not
underneath the ice you were still not
there but hey I was or four minutes too
much too long then they woke me under
the ice wow that's a moment so I come
back from the how do you train your mind
to believe in yourself again at that
moment I actually had 100 i io verk aim
the the fear of death and die there was
no agony that's strange
and that's past my perception of what I
thought it was death you know there and
there is nobody wants to die is there
maybe it's much more beautiful out there
huh we're in the afterlife and now we
got a live eye are not afraid to die I'm
afraid not to live you know quotes and
things but based on experience and so I
really defied death and a fearful death
over there not defying like I did it
know what happened and I learned from it
to take away my fear for death so and
then the other day I only had to do 50
meters which was a biscuit
a couple butterfly kicks and you're
there huh that's it came out happy yeah
yeah okay that was my number one I like
it wreck it
do you face fear now when you go into
some extreme challenge or in any part of
your life a good question any part of
their life because it's all about the
life and actually no my I'm a man on a
mission
no fears oh no no no I'm a man on a
mission I want to take away fear you
know irrational fears traumatic fears
fears created because you do not handle
mental issues nice grief emotion PTSD
trauma depression those things we are
going to tackle and somebody's got to do
this and I should have no fear to
accomplish that mmm you know a man on a
mission should not think am in fear you
should go and accomplish his mission
yeah and be focused so there I am I feel
feel like everybody because it's natural
to mm-hmm
you feel fear failures or you said don't
know I fear I feel you fear like
everybody but it doesn't hold you back
from moving for absolutely not come on
man it's a much too important you've
lived a life dominated by doubt and fear
how do you step into bravery step
that that's how you step in a bravery
step take the step step aggressively
towards your fear and that that step
towards your fear is the step into
bravery because we're per scared of what
we don't know and there is only one way
to learn and to know and that is to
confront that fear you have to step you
have to go and this simple action this
simple
attitude it answers so many questions so
many questions how do you get to the gym
every day you step you go how do you how
do you change your diet you step you go
how do you overcome fear of failure fear
of success or or fear of fear itself you
step and how do you face the fear of the
unknown your step don't wait anymore
don't think anymore don't plan anymore
don't contemplate anymore don't make any
more excuses or justifications don't
rationalize anything else no no and no
instead be aggressive take action now
and what is the first action that you
need to take what's the first step you
need to take the first
step you need to take is just that step
there's this test called the dark triad
test which again anything important like
this nobody ever learned it in school
because schools are too stupid to take
real powerful science and apply it to
life but the dark triad is a worldview
barometer for everybody watching you can
take it there's a different thought free
dark triad tests online it tests for
three main traits negative qualities
narcissism Machiavellianism and being
psychotic and I've personally tested
thousands and thousands of people it's
the most accurate test and what happens
narcissism okay one of the symptoms of a
narcissist it's not just like oh I like
to look in the mirror right that's what
we think of Marcy one of the classic
symptoms is very thin-skinned
they're always offended if you have a
friend that anything you say
constructively they fall apart it's
almost always narcissism even if they're
introverted there's multiple forms
there's introverted narcissism
extroverted exploitative all these
different sub facets of narcissism but
we live in a society that's very
narcissistic you're told like
everybody's a winner
no not everybody's a winner that's like
saying everybody's blonde there's a
definition of what blonde is blonde is
like this yellowish air so you lose
meaning when you start going and
everybody's blonde
well everybody doesn't win and the
sooner you wake up to that that biology
is ruthless man then you get a little
fear in you and when you get a little
fear in you you start listening because
if you're truly afraid you listen let a
little fear come in and drive you in
motivate you fear is normal it's part of
what makes you human you would not be
human or you'd have some crazy condition
if you never felt fear I think the
people who say don't be afraid aren't
giving you practical advice it's be
afraid feel the fear and then step into
it and do it anyway and the more you get
used to taking on those fearful projects
that you're scared of the stronger
you'll get the more resistance you'll
get the higher tolerance you'll get to
do bigger better bolder badder things I
think the trick though is spotting the
fear
here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along there's some moment that
comes along with this with a client or
meeting somebody or an event something
comes along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's gonna stretch
you beyond we've ever done before and
then what you do is you rationalize
saying no I don't have the money to go
to that event I'm too busy to go and do
that thing right now you find the reason
why you can't go and do it you
rationalize it but really deep down the
reason is you're just afraid and until
you spot the fear until you understand
that it's really just the fear then
you're never gonna solve the problem so
step one is understanding when there is
fear step two is then stepping into it
and doing it anyway and a lot of this
stuff which is so subconscious you know
we as human beings are kind of trained
to when we're afraid something's gonna
go wrong and to be safe and so it's
trying to catch that subconscious action
and proactively change it so the example
for me when I was starting my youtube
channel my agent would tell me you have
to go out and do videos in public I want
you to go in on the street
I make your video in public my natural
reaction was fear but I didn't catch it
initially it was the gear won't be as
good in public you know I can't control
the light settings I'm gonna be bouncing
around with the camera it's not gonna be
a great experience for the people
watching why would I do that
I'm rationalizing a reason why I don't
have to do it we're really I'm just
afraid right you could solve all those
problems and he told me stop being
afraid and just go and do it you've got
through it and let me see my own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public I took out it
was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking on the street
and then the postman is there as so as
soon as I see the postman I quiet down
though I could put the camera away
just walking normally
and then when the postman leaves I'm
back to filming and that time I noticed
like I'm doing it because I'm afraid and
I got pissed okay next time
I got a Speak Up next time I got to do
better and so I went out and forced
myself to go and do it again and I was
walking past and there were these
construction workers and instantly again
the the panic sets in like people are
watching the construction workers like
oh they don't really even care about me
what I'm saying what's happening on the
street but I forced myself through it it
was awkward it wasn't great I think I
had to redo it again anyway but I I took
the step I got better at it I recognized
the fear and I jumped into it and now
it's to the point where I'll all make
videos walking down the hall I make
videos when I'm at Disneyland Disney
World you know I'll make videos in the
streets of anywhere and there's still a
moment even now after how many videos
I've done there's still a moment of
who's watching I think it's natural
normal it's not as strong as it used to
be and more importantly it doesn't limit
me from doing the things that I want to
do and so spotting the fear and not
rationalizing it away and not just doing
what your subconscious always does that
keeps you down where you are is so
important being truthful that the reason
why you said no or you're not taking
this opportunities just because you're
afraid and the answer to say no should
never be because I'm afraid you want to
reject your system so whenever that's
the answer because I'm afraid to do it
now you have to do it you know I'm a big
believer that it's no different than
swimming or riding a bike two things
that didn't come natural to me I started
swimming and riding a bike late in my
life you know like I think I don't think
I started swimming if I was nine because
I feared them yeah
but the answer was literally to just
jump into pools or swimming
- just like skinned your knee right -
take it
water you know I just think you do it
like I just like I think the best thing
that could happen to you is if you hear
this advice there's a networking event
in town you go you put on your nice
little Manor media Henry needs head you
walk up you see somebody you're inspired
by it my five minutes with Gary you go
up and go hi cuz John and John looks you
and says get the [ __ ] out of my face I
actually think that would be the best
thing that could ever happen to you yeah
I think the best thing that can happen
to somebody when they fear something is
for them to taste the thing they feared
aggressively and immediately when they
could try something yeah I think that it
just eliminates like you'll literally be
there and whether you go crying in the
bathroom or just like becoming silent or
walking out of there or walking and
getting a you know oh you know
cheeseburger for five seconds and coming
back I think the great thing that would
happen to you is that you'd be like okay
well that happened now what like once
people understand and taste the thing
they fear it becomes a hell of a lot
less scary fear is the great indicator
sooner or later you will experience fear
when you start taking new actions at new
levels in fact if you aren't then you're
probably not doing enough of the right
things
fear isn't bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek and then to embrace fear is
actually a sign that you're doing what
is needed to move in the right direction
what is fear anyway I mean really does
it even exist is it real I know it feels
real when you're experiencing it but
admit it most of the time what you fear
doesn't even occur fear for the most
part is provoked by emotions not
rational thinking chances are that when
you were a child you've found fear in
irrational things the boogeyman under
the bed for example adults have their
own boogeymen the unknown rejection
failure fear success and on and on for
example if you're afraid to call a
client finish that sign
you should call that Clinton fear
speaking with the boss is an indication
you should march into his office and ask
for a moment of his time everyone
everyone experiences fear on some level
fear doesn't just tell you what to do it
also tells you when to do it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same
the time is now the time is always now
and when you experience fear it's a sign
that the best time to take action is
that very moment now the only thing that
will make a difference in that moment of
fear is action failure comes in many
forms it occurs whether you act or you
don't act regardless of the outcome I
would say it's far preferable to fail
while doing something then to fail by
over preparing while someone else walks
up and scoops up your dreams fear is a
sign to do whatever it is you fear and
do it quickly so many people look at
fear or even doubt but they look at fear
as if it's the emotional enemy you know
it's the enemy emotion like oh I can
deal with compassion I can do it love I
can do it understanding but when fear
comes oh my god bad thing No first of
all change your relationship to fear
I've said this before fear is not the
enemy the feeling of fear is just like
any other emotion fear is actually
informing you fear is telling you that
you need to do something either do more
research get some support get some
insight study a little more slow down
fear is actually feeding you so then ask
yourself the question what do I need to
do think or go get to dissipate this
fear because remember fear is fear
becomes present when you've made up
something that could happen in the
future and it makes you afraid right now
like oh my god I'm afraid I can get hurt
in this relationship oh my god I'm
afraid lose my money well you're just
projecting a story that you made up then
back into that fear go okay wait
then what do I need to do to minimize
the fear that I might get hurt what do I
need to do to minimize the fear that I
might lose my money what do I need to do
of course you can't up 100% eliminate
the possibility but you can greatly
reduce the chances
asking what am i afraid of what am i
afraid that's gonna happen and then
secondly recognize that fear doesn't
mean stop people think oh I'm afraid let
me stop okay that's a choice to stop
fear doesn't necessarily mean stop fear
might mean proceed with caution or
proceed with more strategy fear does it
whenever I'm feeling fear it doesn't
tell me this I don't you think now -
stop with the fear I do think to slow
down go get some help go get some inside
voice my fear so that it's not just all
in my head recognize that fear is going
to come in when you're playing bigger
than you've ever played before I say if
your knees aren't knocking and your
teeth are chattering just a little
atleast then you're not playing big
enough the bigger you play the more
you're gonna feel your knees knock and
you don't hear your teeth chatter and
I'm always playing big I'm always
filling my knees knock and I'm always
hearing my teeth chatter but I've
created a relationship with that fear to
go hold on let's say fears right here
fear
what are you telling me because fear
really is it's it's a story it's it's
something you think could happen and
could it happen yeah but could it not
happen yeah so
don't try to outrun fear don't try to
outrun doubt and definitely don't wait
until and fear are gone before you move
find out what doubt and fear needs to
dissipate into the nothingness that it
always was what does it need and then
understand that action brings clarity so
the more you move forward the more
action you're in the more clarity you
get because action breeds clarity and
clarity comes with action so many times
you're sitting on the sidelines waiting
waiting to get completely clear before
you take any action and clarity is
waiting for you to get an action to
create clarity so be willing be willing
to play full out a little nervous
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Hugh Jackman on how to embrace fear
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that the three questions I
want to make sure we're moving from
watching the video to actually taking
action so here are three questions to
think about either write down the
answers yourself on a journal talk about
them with a friend or leave them in the
comments below
here we go question number one what are
you fearing too much that has to stop
today question number two what is this
fear preventing you from accomplishing
and question number three how will you
face this fear thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
you suffer from bit of anxiety when
you're in front of the camera hmm but
that you name your you're confident
personality Frank yeah oh my god and
you're in joy and you're anxious
personality Charles the most scared I've
ever been was being asked to sing at the
MCG for the bladders like up and I'm a
big rugby fan I was brought up in Sydney
so rugby was my sport and I said come
and sing and I actually had a panic
attack the night before because all the
people I was at a dinner party and
people were telling stories of how
careers had finished by singing a dad
doesn't to her anymore I'll tell you
that does not happen and that someone
got up and saying it acapella got
off-key got booed literally singing the
anthem and I have never been more scared
than that moment and I what happened to
me in film was it was random it would
appear sometimes and that was something
I never encounter I understand if you're
scared of heights you always get a
heights but some days I'll be fine and
then some days I would just get nervous
and then to get in my head so I don't
know if you guys know Anthony Robbins
you know the other motivational
motivational do yes yeah I mean he does
motivator he's not really motivational
guy actually he's really quite brilliant
in breaking down how we think the
patterns of behavior we have and so I
met him we were mates I never went to
him to I never went to one of his
workshops we were just friends and I
really I said mate I want to come to you
professionally I need to ask you a
question and that's he said to me what
the biggest mistake people make with
fear is saying I'm scared get I hate
this get it out I don't want you near my
life this is not helping me and you get
obviously really wound up so he said
you've got to remember the times we feel
confident name that character name the
character that feels scared and as
you're walking on a set realize that the
fear is good that a got you where you
are that it makes you work their fears
sometimes actually goes on I better work
really hard on this film like when I
with lame is I was really nervous so he
said that fear embrace it worked really
hard and on that day when you walk on
set Charles Charlie Charles thanks but I
don't need you right now
and then be Frank as in a total [ __ ]
don't care about it enough and that
somehow to switch to me in one occasion
we get nervous now turistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video